RETO MEIER: Hello, and welcome
to "This Week in Android
Development" for July 1, 2013.
My name is Reto Meier.
Last week, we released the
latest in a long line of
"DevBytes" from Chet Haase.
Chet's forgotten more about
Android animations than most
of us will ever know, so we're
recording what he still
retains before his memory
fails entirely.
The Android Design in Action
team took their metaphoric
scalpels to Google Play last
week, with special guests
Marco Paglia and Owen Otto from
the Android design team.
Google is redesigning apps
written by Googlers.
We must go deeper.
I personally had the pleasure of
presenting some Android pro
tips to the delightfully
acronym-ed NSBE during their
Android summit here at Google.
For our games developers, we
released the Firewall Defense
Google Play games web sample.
And the Google Play for
Education folks continue to
expand their program, with
developers now able to submit
their apps to Google Play for
Education for use in their
ongoing pilot programs.
Speaking of pilots, Android
Studio has added integrated
cloud support through support
for Google Cloud Endpoints,
allowing you to quickly and
easily create an App Engine
backend for your apps directly
from your IDE.
We also saw a lot of new apps
released on Google Play,
including music discovery and
sharing app Soundwave; an
update to photography,
discovery, and sharing app
EyeEm; an update that includes
Holo styling and tablet
support for French TV app Tele
Loisirs; as well as an email
management app, Boomerang.
Those of us based in the US will
be taking a few days off
this week to celebrate the
independence of this great
nation from the kings of
an island-based empire
some 200 years ago.
Personally, I would have
called it America Day.
But I've been told that here,
every day is America Day.
In any case, that means we'll
be barbecuing rather than
broadcasting from our Mountain
View Studio.
But our colleagues in Sydney
and London will be holding
down the fort in our absence,
starting with Ankur Kotwal,
who has generously translated
some "DevBytes" into an
Australian patois.
So if you talk like a proper
Aussie, you'll want
to check this out.
Good on ya.
Nick and Rich will also be
broadcasting a "DevByte
Backstage" next Thursday.
As always, you can keep track
of what's coming up and any
last-minute changes at
developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
That's all for "This
Week in Android
Development" for July 1, 2013.
Join us for this
week's "Android
Developer Live" broadcast.
And remember to make the most
of this night like you're
going to die young.